hello  to be tastier headstock is for your kind  of flavor what's that it's kool-aid  liquid you are kool-aid people get  freaked out when you drink on your own  head what you got there dude J and Duke  talking action figures my idea love it  it takes place in ancient Cleveland haha  Cleveland I love it babe I'm not your  babe you weren't saying that this  morning when you're like mmm  soap vanilla tastes better than milk on  cereal it has 50% more calcium really  Leslie guess what today is  it's hump day rest is here on the wings  of lunesta and stay asleep  you can wake up feeling rested  hey buddy let's take a little walk  you're gonna want a palm tree up the  fish cheap unicorny until the smiley  face at the soccer shoe till the second  seahorse on your teapot and then you  should be lightbulbs you get all that  rubber duckie